good afternoon it's great to be here as
Susan said the third attempt so I am
almost barely able to believe I'm
actually standing here but anyway I'm
delighted to to talk to you at Yale
about one of the great enthusiasms of my
life recently in fact one might say it
took over my life completely recently
which is UCL center for digital
humanities and how how it's progressed
it is just over officially it is just
over three years old now it probably
coming up four years old in terms of its
actual original conception and so what
I'm going to talk about today is really
how it all came about what we've learnt
and I hope that some of that at least
will be of interest in terms of your
thoughts about how digital humanities
might progress at Yale okay so every
talk about digital humanities these days
apparently seems to have to start with
definitions generally i don't like
trying to define digital humanities i
take a nike attitude to it which is just
do it but nevertheless i think that we
need to think about what is ucl's view
of digital humanities and in some ways
it is slightly different from other
views of d.h partly as i will argue
because of the way there's our Center
came to be and some of the what turn out
to have been constraints but also rather
happenstance led useful constraints in
many ways and we think of digital
humanities as okay the application of
digital or computational research to the
arts and humanities yet so far so on
controversial that's what most people
think digital humanities is we also like
to include and in fact think he's
actually essential to include cultural
heritage practice so digital techniques
in the museum sector working with
galleries I was until recently the
head of department department chair for
the Department of Information studies at
UCL so I think very much in these terms
about archives and libraries so that is
one thing that comes about because of
innocence my own disciplinary basis I
just happen to be in the department
information studies as did my colleague
Melissa terrace and we'd been doing
digital humanities for a long time
before the actual Center was set up so I
think in a sense this is partly what
drove the way we we think about it but I
think it's also important to think about
D H as the use of humanities methods to
study the digital so as Susan told you
I'm interested in social media yes as in
how social media is used by museums how
social media is used as a serious
research tool but I'm also interested in
it as a phenomenon if you like in
questions of how do we construct our own
identity in digital in digital places if
you like and I think therefore you know
that is a question that humanists have
been asking forever you know how do we
express ourselves how do we construct
our identities how do we communicate
with other people what is it if you like
to be human and I think those questions
of what is it to be human are just as
relevant for a digital humanities as
those questions of how do we apply
digital techniques to humanities or
cultural heritage research problems um
we are a little bit different in the way
we do digital humanities at UCL I will
shortly tell you the peculiar story of
how it came about but the result of all
this is that we are very very blessed to
be able to communicate communicate and
collaborate with you not only humanity
schools but also our colleagues in
engineering
and computer science and one of the
things we realized very early was that
the version of DX that we want to do is
not about subordinating the computer guy
to the humanities researcher what we're
trying to do is to create new knowledge
and come up with meaningful research for
both parts of the partnership or even
several parts of the partnership if you
could include cultural heritage as well
so the idea is that not only should the
humanities scholar get some interesting
research out of this and find you know
create new knowledge but the the
engineer or the computer scientist
should too for example um that I mean
there are numerous examples of this but
one of the examples that I like to talk
about is the research of one of our
engineering colleagues now in the day
job as it were he researches the use of
complex materials and one of the people
he works with his NASA but in the other
part of his existence he actually does
3d scanning of museum objects we have a
fantastic Museum of Egyptian archaeology
called the Petrie Museum off the
Flinders Petrie who founded it and the
problem of that it is that Everett like
everything at UCL there isn't enough
space so a lot of their artifacts are
actually packed away and you can't see
them now of course if you 3d scan them
you're not actually necessarily you're
not seeing the same object it is a
digital representation of an object it
doesn't make up for the lack of the
object but it's better than not not
seeing as tall and in doing so we have
not only found out a lot about digital
representations of museum objects so
we've created some interesting research
collaboratively with museum sector but
Stuart has also therefore advance his
research into complex materials so
you're getting and you know a serious
piece of engineering research out of
this as well as the humanities search
that's not the only example but that
that's one of them and that I think is
extremely important and it is quite
distinctive to the way we do
h at UCL I think it's also relevant to
this that we're the only I mean depends
which grow global rankings you read but
in general UCL a--'s roundabout up there
in the kind of top ten and we're the
only University in that kind of area
that has a nice cool which is important
because I schools all Department of
Information studies as we call them are
very into collaborating you know we tend
to have members of staff who were
information professionals you know who
have been practicing archivists
publishers librarians they understand
the importance of collaborating with
other disciplines they don't always work
in a single scholar paradigm and that's
extremely important because to do D H
effectively in most cases it is
important to collaborate and this is not
something that humanity scholars are
always happy about doing so one of the
things that having a nice cool does is
it gives you a as it were a
collaboration platform which is you know
not always present the other thing that
we have which of course you do at Yale
as well is really world-class museums
art galleries special collections and
that that again is very important and I
think that's driven our kind of attitude
to D H research because people in the
museum's and special collections are
very interested in things digital and
actually with some of the first people
that said that's great let's collaborate
as I say our engineering colleague 3d
scanning museum objects and that I think
came as much from the the museum side as
that came from the engineering side so I
think all of these factors are you know
give us our distinctive way of doing d.h
if you like um but what do we actually
do you know how do we do t8 well one of
the things that I realized very early
when we started you see LDH is that I
could not really use the same model as
some of the what I'd call first page
digital humanity
centers such as our colleagues at King's
College London who've had a center for
digital humanities for many years when
they started up as it were any
Paleolithic era from digital terms there
were so few people doing digital
humanities that if if scholars wanted
access to digital resources or the
computing power necessary to do what
they wanted they really had to go to a
center where they could work with
technical people and get the you know
have enough computer capacity now what I
realized when we began you CLD edges we
couldn't do that they were clearly
people all over the university and
literally all over the university who
were doing things that we might now call
digital humanities whether they were
actually calling them digital humanities
at the time is another question and so
it was very clear that we couldn't have
this kind of idea of everybody must come
to us everybody must come to a physical
center if they wanted in and that we
were sort of gatekeepers to D H we
couldn't do that so there had to be
another model and that model was in a
sense that of a network so we began by
saying well let's find out what is there
out there you know what who's doing what
and connecting people so I was saying at
the workshop this morning my then
department chair was horrified when I
said that we were going to do this
because he said well this is terrible
you'll stop doing your own work and keep
on help other people um and actually he
was right in many ways but it's been
it's been a very interesting experience
to do so but the point about it is that
we're there to not to tell people how
they should do digital humanities or
whether they should do digital
humanities but try and put different
people together so you know a lot of
what we've been doing is someone will
come with an idea or a potential project
and say does this make sense to you and
actually do you know anybody else who is
interested in this or is there someone
else I should talk to and then a lot of
what we're doing is saying great yes you
should talk to that person or you should
talk to Santo or and therefore a lot of
a lot of what we've been doing is this
kind of broker
role of creating a network of linking
people of having people actually working
on similar things and who simply did not
know that somebody else existed who was
interested in that type of area and that
means making connections not just in the
university but outside the university so
you know with cultural heritage
organizations outside universities
sometimes with commercial companies and
that that is very sort of central to
what we feel we do so yes we are a
center but we I see I think of us of us
in a kind of hypertext theory way of
being the hub of a network we're not
really just the sort of center that
sucks things in and what we try and do
as I say I I am NOT the kind of person
that tries to define what people should
be doing in digital humanities I tend if
you feel that if people think they're
doing digital humanities they probably
are and therefore we try and be as
inclusive as possible and we try not to
say yes will work with this person no we
can't work with that person we try and
find some connections and some people
who will work together even if it's not
something we are personally expert in um
as I said it's very important that we do
have these links with cultural heritage
and this is not only our museums and
collections it's also practicing artists
we have a fantastic group of digital
artists at the Slade School of Art which
is of course world renowned art school
and it's very interesting to have
conversations with them about making
ditch to work about how digital work is
preserved but also our position in
London is great because it means we are
we are literally physically right in the
middle of huge numbers of museums
galleries publishers libraries you name
it so we've got you know currently we
are collaborating with the British
Museum the Victoria and Albert Museum
that's their science museum the National
Gallery the British Library the the
National Archives it just kind of it
just happens really it just so happens
where we are at ironic when you're
considering that we are a digital entity
we don't have a physical center but
where we physically are does drive the
way we work because we are you know we
have those connections so so easily to
the cultural heritage sector also you
know what they're for how do we foster
this network how do we make these
connections work well we've done quite a
lot of things that are specifically
aimed at networking so we have things
called digital excursions where we visit
parts of the university or parts of the
world outside the university where
interesting digital things are going on
so we might go to the the cave in
computer science we've I've just there
was just an excursion that I've not been
able to get to because I'm here looking
at universities on the data center and
how they actually know how the you know
the vast amounts of computing power
actually look when you physically see
them we've been to the British Museum we
missed the British Library forest of
digital exhibitions and the idea of
these is not so much pedagogical but but
to foster networking so the the idea is
that people might be interested to see
what's going on digitally but the talk
is always very short and the networking
activity which is importantly wine and
everybody seems to think this is
terribly quaint nibbles apparently
people don't yeah obviously people don't
use the word nibbles but what I mean by
that is you know little canapes and
stuff like that that you give people and
the idea is we just get people talking
and it's through those connections that
people make that often you know new
activities are spun off this just came
about by accident when we had the
internal launch event and one of the
professors from the English faculty said
this is great you know we should have
more reasons why we can just get
together and have a free glass one and I
thought right that's it then digital
excursions happened we have things that
are more pedagogical Corp alias
introductions where we give short talks
at lunchtime on kind of digital
techniques and
that kind of fairly low level stuff
intended for people like graduate
students but we get some faculty members
at those as well we have a student
graduate student led group called
decoding digital humanities which came
up really rather by accident with some
graduate students who said they would
just like to put together a reading
group about you know kind of seminal
texts in digital humanities if you like
and that you know has been very
interesting we tend we have invited
speakers we kind of grabbed people when
they happen to be in London and say will
you please come and give a talk to our
students we also have got a lot of
social media profile which I'll talk
about in on its own so we tweet we blog
we do podcasting of course we do
research so we have funded research
projects we also teach we have the only
dual designation digital humanities
course in the world as far as I know
which can be an MA or an MSC depending
on how technical or not the students
decide to make their course because it's
there's a lot of optional content and we
help sponsor some digital groups such as
digital classicists we as I say one of
the things that's terribly important
about you CLD h's we do good parties
parties turn out to be very very useful
for creating new research in digital
humanities so you know we steal
ourselves and make ourselves give
parties on a regular basis so that
people can come along and find out what
we do but we also do go out and take
part in more directed shall we say
public engagement activities so we will
run joint workshops with the British
Museum for example and all of these
really are activities that are how do I
put it really about profile raising you
know nobody knew we existed when I
before we have started the centre really
nobody knew what it was I did even my
own colleagues except for one of them um
and then nobody knew what she did on her
but the thing is that that is therefore
we had to create a sense of we need to
you know people need to know who
our people need to know what we do so he
needed to do as many things as we
possibly could so that people would find
out what it is we did um and here comes
the money bit how did we come into being
well this is where I tell the strange
story of how you CLD h-happened it in
many ways it was a concatenation of luck
and just things happening at the
university level which we were able to
ride on the back of this thing called
the provost strategic development fund
was created which is an idea of having a
kind of central fund which was intended
to fund startup activities for a couple
of years with the idea that they it's it
was a sort of almost an experiment to
see if things would be able to make
themselves sustainable so we had two
years of funding from promise to
strategic development fund and the idea
was then then we had to be able to run
ourselves financially after two years
the reason why it's a curious story is
just that everything seemed to come
together at once and it was simply
because of a kind of lucky email that
one Dean sent to another Dean and in
fact no it was that who has become a
dean of engineering at the time he was
had a computer science and he heard one
of my colleagues will and McCarty give a
talk about digital humanities in
Cambridge and emails the Dean and I
happened to be acting associate dean at
the time and he just sent this email
saying I've heard this talk about this
thing called digital humanities we
should do that here and it only came to
me because I always associate dean not
because i was doing anything to do with
digital parities and i said well that's
funny i do digital humanities and he
said oh well that's great we should talk
and from that everything began and we
had we held a town meeting in a lecture
hall something like this and slightly
bigger and I
I hoped that we'd have more than two or
three people in it and we just had a
little meeting about what we did and you
know a few people talked about their
work and their came to it over a hundred
people from every part of UCL from every
faculty and it was at that point I
thought okay we're onto something here I
don't know how this is going to work but
it's going to work and at that point
we've been put together the well the
vice-provost research came up to me at
the beginning of that just as i was
about to give the talk to start off the
meeting and he said and what do you want
out of this meeting and i thought at the
time I thought I actually don't know
what I want but I thought that's
probably not what I say to the vice
provost research so I said I think I
might want to center for digital
humanities and he said that sounds good
come and see me i hope you write a bid
and that was it so as I say in a sense a
kind of happenstance a sort of lucky
time but we did have to make this money
work for us so in 2011 we launched the
ma MSC and really because teaching
income is more reliable than researching
country do research of course but it's
not a reliable source of income and it
was also very important that I say we
did have this buy-in from senior
management the Provost obviously funded
it from his development fund the vice
provost research was interested in what
we were doing the deans of both the
faculties of engineering and outs and
humanities were enthusiastic because the
Dean of engineering or the soon-to-be
dean of engineering has an MA in art as
well as being a computer scientist and
the Dean of Arts and Humanities as was
was a book scholar but also happened to
do some digital humanities himself so
while he was not a techie exactly he got
it he understood the reason for it so
we've had a kind of very important
support from from senior management and
I think that's been absolutely crucial I
don't think this thing can be done
without the the buy-in from people who
put crudely control the finances what's
the focus of what we do I mean again
this is partly driven by where we were
and what we were
we've always had a particular interest
in studying users of digital humanities
or digital resources in the humanities
and in cultural heritage partly because
that's what I happen to do but it's also
particularly relevant in terms of
suddenly people got interested in this
because of things like the rise of Erie
ders tablets social media happened and
suddenly that this whole idea of what
are people doing with this digital staff
became particularly relevant as i said
this collaboration with cultural
heritage builds on some of the strengths
that we already had particularly in
engineering also the in the engineering
faculty there was 3d scanning but also
my my colleague Melissa terrace and my
other colleagues Tim virus in computer
science has already serious expertise an
interest in image processing and working
with digital images in using digital
images to foster research particularly
in study of ancient documents and in
archaeology and you know we've just got
interested in this whole social media
thing I've been interested in social
media ever since social media was called
virtual communities and there is kind of
a difference and there's a history of
this and I've been doing that for ages
so it's that is what I mean about
applying humanities methods of the
digital I think studying social media is
digital humanities because it's thinking
about you know how are we what are we
how do we express ourselves in that
particular way you know how is it to be
human in digital space um so you talked
about you know things we do what the
research we do is how we've made
ourselves a masters course but what is
it that makes us different from other
digital technology centers well one of
the things is we don't do service
computing we this came about really
rather by accident but that service in
terms of helping support people with
computing activities and problems is
actually very important but it costs
money and it was very clear that the
pump priming funds we had were going to
be pretty small and it would buy some
time by out and some admin support and
that was going to be it and the idea was
that we would create income and the to
wait creating come is through research
and teaching it is not through doing
support so we don't do support we might
like to do that in the future if we you
know acquire some more money but the
point is we don't we don't do that now
what I hadn't really realized in doing
that and I subsequently have realized is
that that gives us a different profile
it's not people thinking oh these are
people in the computing services or
something aren't they they think of us
as faculty members who happen to do this
thing called digital humanities and it's
also meant that we we have collaborates
a lot with our computer scientist
colleagues which is relatively rare
digital humanities is often something
that exists way outside computer science
but and we've we've collaborated with
people like our colleagues masters
students because they need projects and
we need some people to produce stuff
because we don't have support folks so
that's actually produced some really
good results because it's getting
students involved we now get our own
students involved in doing project work
I think also that a lot of previous
digital humanities centers have rather
grown up on a sort of they just happened
basis I know that the center at Kings
grew out of being part the computing
services and it we are slightly
different in that we we were founded in
this sort of particular way at this
particular moment and so we've we've had
to adapt to our circumstances as I say
this is the reason why we don't sue
service computing this is the reason why
we you know because the Dean of
engineering was involved we collaborate
very much with computer science in the
weather other people don't because we
don't have a physical space we do a lot
of networking activities and actually
those constraints have ended up being
strengths
and so we sort of created our own model
Ford eh thinking well here we have some
established activities already here we
have people doing this research how
could we best make these connections
work we also take digital identity very
very seriously we tweet a lot we blog we
have a website but we did a huge amount
of work on the website to create a look
this beautiful logo that you saw at the
beginning of my talk was created by one
of our PhD students oddly who's now
actually become a professional designer
having finished his PhD and he just has
this talent for producing fantastic
visual identity work and that logo has
literally gone round the world people
just recognize it it just does express
what we are and you know had it not been
for having this incredibly talented PhD
student we probably wouldn't have had a
logo in the first place because we
wouldn't have had the money to pay for
one and just these are sort of peculiar
happens dances but once we have that we
do take it very seriously and we do try
and be very conscious about what we're
doing in digital space as well what that
says about us and you know this is some
of some of this has been remarkably
successful so for example we created or
melissa creatives at the beginning some
ideas of how you some little posters
with some images on or some kind of
thought provoking text on that we would
just literally print out and stick up
around UCL to just create some sort of
oh I wonder what that is and with our
website you are on you know come and
find out more curiously we were never
really able to do much of that that at
UCL because the Provost objects to
posters being stuck up around places so
actually that didn't really work in
physical space but where it did work was
the Melissa put some of these up on her
blog and people saw them and said these
are fantastic these are really great
could we have some so she made the
high-resolution digital images available
and these have now gone
to the neh office of digital humanities
so they're in Washington DC some of our
posters and there are no other
universities that do th have also
printed up some of our posters and so
you know that was never meant to happen
but they're very attractive posters and
they express some interesting ideas and
it's the kind of thing that other people
who do th want to show people and so
that you know that's just been a matter
of very good design lovely logo and
other people want to get involved the
other thing that you're probably
gathering is that we work very
extensively with people outside academia
I think partly because of our interest
in studying how people use digital
resources and but then working with
museums and cultural heritage we see it
is very important that digital
humanities is not simply a field that
speaks only to other academics that it
needs to speak to people in the cultural
heritage sector and equally those people
who use cultural heritage resources so
visitors to museums users of libraries
those kind of things this fits again
very well with UCL's emphasis on public
engagement on the public understanding
of science or humanities um as I said I
think this is it what we've done is it's
important that it does fit in with what
you see Elsie's is important just one of
the reasons why the vice-provost
research was enthusiastic about digital
humanities was that he had recently
launched what are called the Grand
Challenges these being big research
areas with the idea that scholars from
all sorts of different areas might get
involved in questions about global
health or sustainable cities in culture
action interaction and human well-being
and it's not always easy to involve
humanities scholars in this because many
humanities scholars prefer to do singles
gotta research it I think it could be
seen that digital humanities was going
to offer collaboration and the potential
of collaboration so this fitted very
well with this kind of
traditional priority as as was then just
being developed because we wanted to do
interdisciplinary things we didn't have
to be forced we actually enjoy it this
is not always the case with all
humanities scholars as I've said we've
got the support of our senior management
which is very very important and also
that we that both the directors of
museums and collections and of library
services are very interested in what we
do and get digital humanities and I
think that's been terribly important for
the way that our collaboration has
developed oddly the other stuff I do in
my life turns out to have been quite
useful so I told you the story about
hearing about digital humanities just
because I was acting as what we call Phi
Steen but you would call associate dean
i think for research at the time I then
really wasn't in the plan at all but
just happened to become department chair
of my department and this has given me a
sort of sense of I've got insight into
the way that the institutional strategy
goes in the way the institutional
strategy is developing because of doing
my arm what I think you'd call service
roles and this turns out have been very
useful because it's you know what we had
to do as I've said it was make ourselves
indispensable my thought was when we
began this period with pump priming
money we have to be so indispensable
that people could not imagine UCL
without you CLD age when we came to the
end of the funding period and i think
that's now true oddly enough but it
meant we had to see we had to work out
what the university thought i was
important and be part of it whatever it
was this was very hard work but
nevertheless it was you know it was
therefore very useful to have this
insight into the way the institution
works the way the institution wants to
work um so what have we learnt as a
result of this I think it's terribly
important that digital humanities as I
say I wanted it to be so embedded in the
fabric of UCL that it to unpick it would
have been unthinkable and that we have
done
but we so therefore we need to be at the
center of everything if there was a new
initiative we want to do part of it if
people said will you do such-and-such we
said yes we didn't you know we're not
these old geeks who do stuff with
technology we are what we are and we're
part of you know we're part of the
center of what's going on at the
University it was clear therefore that
people needed to understand what it was
we did you know people still kind of say
what is digital humanities my current
dean is forever saying what is digital
humanities and I say you must be the
only person in the university that
doesn't know yet but seriously we worked
very very hard publicity we worked very
very hard you know as I've said blogging
tweeting putting up posters doing these
networking events just to kind of keep
our profile really high because we had
to have this sense of proving our worth
if we didn't prove our worth if we
didn't make make money work but also
make the intellectual case for being
important to the institution that was it
end of center after two years and
therefore I think as I've said what we
needed to do was not in to take from the
universities but to give to see how we
could benefit other parts of the
university so my new job which I means
quantity this year is to as you've seen
to be deputy director of big doctor'll
training center which is a collaboration
between ourselves Kings and the School
of Advanced Study which is part of the
University of London and one of the
things when we were writing that via
this is a multi-million pound venture
for to fund all studentships in the arts
and humanities so anybody who gets
funded in the arts and humanities at
these three universities to do a PhD
student is being funded by this body and
one of the things we said in the bid was
we are distinctive because we will offer
training to all the graduate students in
digital humanities I was in every
graduate student will have training in
digital humanities that's something that
made us really distinctive and that
something that our main rivals being
Oxford and Cambridge couldn't offer
they don't have they don't have some
very very good digital emeritus projects
but they don't have the kind of central
infrastructure and they don't have the
teaching infrastructure to offer that
kind of thing so again you can see what
we were doing there was being useful you
know being helpful to that bid and by
all accounts it really did help the mid
get funded and it's the second largest
amount of money of all of the consortium
that were funded so you know somebody
liked it as I said what we we've also
worked very hard at reaching out beyond
academia this again works with UCL
strategy because we have done a lot of
work on on public engagement I know
public humanities public scholarship is
a very important and well-understood
thing in the u.s. it's not it hasn't
been in the UK and it's something that's
relatively recently being developed and
UCL takes this stuff extremely seriously
so our idea was to take part in public
engagement and to take d.h outside
academia the curator project for example
is a project using static iPads and
creating interactive labels so that
instead of people being told you know
there are traditional labels as well
which tell you this is an aardvark our
interactive labels will say pose
questions to their visitor to say do you
think it is reasonable to display human
remains in a museum and people actually
didn't want to the visitors want to
engage in a in a dialogue with that they
want to answer questions they want to
give their views they want to tell us
what they like about museum which is not
what we expected but having done a study
on that one of the PhD students use
who's really whose initiative it was
that curator came about has proved that
people really do want to do this and
that if trusted they will actually write
perfectly reasonable comments um
so working with the public has been a
massive opportunity for us and
particularly things using crowdsourcing
web two point naught social media to
allow this sort of two-way dialogue the
transcribe Bentham project is a very
well-known project now which applies
crowd sourcing techniques to jeremy
bentham's the corpse of jeremy bentham's
work and it's amazing really when it
began I had no idea that there will be
so many people out there in the rest of
the world who would enjoy transcribing
Bentham's handwriting because it's
actually not easy but it turns out that
they do and they love it and there are
thousands of people who transcribed some
bets I invent them and this is actually
amazing and it's remarkably
transformative because what it's doing
is allowing anyone out there on the
internet to be part of the scholarly
process in a way is you know normally
these sort of documents would only have
been available to historians perhaps to
philosophers but basically says scholars
or to Special Collections librarians or
archivists you know nobody else would
have seen these things and this really
changes the way that we can think about
involving the rest of the world in the
scholarly process and it's amazing how
much people want to do it so what we're
doing is is kind of raising awareness of
what we do but but always doing
high-quality scholarship it's very
important that what we're doing is good
and it's it's interesting and it's well
produced in digital terms but its
scholarship is very sound too and that
that's we take very seriously because
that is what will make people use these
things so are we indispensable um yes I
hope we are nobody is absolutely
indispensable but I think I think we
have embedded ourselves so much into UCR
life that I think people would find it
difficult and people have said to me I
think this is a great that they've
actually said god I can't imagine
digital humanities you know not being at
UCL anymore it's you know it is there
it's you know it's one of the globally
most recognized digital humanities
centers not even a corny juelz that's
what the people do take nacional said
about us and it's just you know it's one
of the things that you see L is known
for now we've
still got some things that we want to do
we still don't have we have some
fantastic students from the US we have
some fantastic students master students
from the EU and the rest the world but
we have very few UK students it's very
odd that students in the UK almost seem
to not know we exist so when a try and
work out how are we going to communicate
to undergraduates that they might want
to do masters work in digital humanities
equally we need to think about well are
we going to have some undergraduate
program to digital humanities how are we
going to make that work and in a sense
how are we going to create the capacity
to expand because the irony of all this
is we've worked so hard at it and we've
got so you know popular if you like that
we are literally at capacity none of us
has any more capacity to take on
anything else you know we've got we've
all got as many PhD students as we can
take we were in all the teacher we can
do we're doing all the research we can
do and there's nothing else we can do
with the present levels of staffing so
we've got to think about how we going to
get resources to get more staffing in
because otherwise our very success is
going to be a problem for us we have to
think about how to fund PhD students as
I say on the deputy director of this new
initiative but even then the money is
short for funding PhD students so we
want to think how we're going to create
the next digital humanities generation
of scholars and where are we going to
get that money from we also have to be
adaptable to the way things change we
have been adaptable to change in the way
that we've set up but we have to be
adaptable in future so some digital
humanities centers get very bound up
with the person who founded them and
when that person leaves then that the
digital humanities center can can wobble
a bit well just I mean something in
instances just ceased to exist now it
was an accident that I ended up being
department chair it was not something I
had planned for and I didn't mean to
give up being director I became
co-director of digital humanities when I
became department chair and then
gradually it became clear that it really
needed a full-time director and that was
not going to be me because I was doing
too many other things but I think in a
funny way that's a good thing
again it's a it's a constraint but it's
a good thing because it means that we've
had to deal with the idea of okay now
who takes this on and melissa is now
director and is taking the center in you
know fantastic directions and it's more
and more vibrant and it's doing great
new things and there it you know it's
it's taken it again to a higher level
very far from being you know bound into
the person that was the first director
so I think that's very important we need
to have the ability to change and adapt
we need some of our activities that we
do now we you know if they don't turn
out to be appropriate in future well we
won't do them and some of the activities
for example the graduate student led
reading group depend on the enthusiasm
of various different graduate students
and some are more enthusiastic than
others so sometimes we go through cycles
of you know positive and you know lots
of activity and sometimes slightly less
activity and that's the sort of the
adaptive changed I think we we still
need to do and I think it's something
that you know we don't want to get kind
of tied into a particular way of doing
things so I think those are things that
we need to look at for the future but I
think yes as I say perhaps not
absolutely indispensable but i hope i
hope that we're there to stay thank you
very much
you